is this a misleading headline to get you
to tune in at 10:00 tune in at 10:00 to
learn that it is hi I'm masculine name
and in between giving you the local news
I'll gently be flirting with my decades
younger co-worker because I'm from a
different time we've got two experts
from a thank taken one person in Mill of
their career let's go to them live right
now I'm only here to plug my book
I'm also straight white male I'm really
worried that this appearance is the peak
of my career
I'm extremely good-looking and better
dressed which means it's time for
Entertainment News you'll never guess we
found out about a celebrity who hasn't
done a decent movie and over a decade
all while watching him from an area that
was creepy and definitely illegal for us
to be I'm emphasizing strange words not
because it conveys any part of the story
but because this is how you expect us to
speak these moving graphic stricture
childish mind into paying attention now
gentlemen tell me more about fear
yes fear is what makes people watch a
southern state passed a law to make sure
everyone's clear they hate gay people
there was an explosion in a country you
assume is in the Middle East what movies
set in a four location with an all-white
cast will you be seeing this summer
scientists announced advice you enjoy
may be good for you in quantities much
smaller than you consume it in let me
tell you a personal anecdote that you
don't care about earthquake destroys
city and foreign country that you'll
forget about because something not
nearly as bad will happen closer to home
provocative question to put an unproven
idea into your head our choice of words
indicate that this might be true even
though it's definitely not yelling like
my job depends on it because it does
trying to get one thing yelling over you
so you can't talk also not letting him
talk trying to just the news lines below
me are probably more important but we're
gonna talk about what gets ratings now
let me say something inflammatory that's
gonna make everyone else react a sequel
no one asked for is coming out this
summer and it will be trashed a major
corporation issued a recall this evening
on a product of theirs that you won't
even check to see if it applies to you a
movie based on a book based on a comic
book about Hollywood not having any new
ideas follow us on Twitter and
why you need to tune in anyway I don't
think we've changed anybody's mind here
tune in tomorrow for the exact same [ __ ]
fake chatter face tracking paper makes
snapping pages fingers mr. dinner
tonight
absolutely not fake chattering papers
second papers that in papers